el ciclón Gabriel dejó un sendero de
devastación en la vida de los habitantes
de Nueva Zelanda es el caso de tajuranji
rururu residente de Caracas quien vio
como su casa se llenó de lodo
ha pasado por aquí a través de los
dormitorios la cocina y todos los
armarios los voluntarios ayudaron a esta
mujer mayor tan solo uno de los
damnificados que dejó el ciclón
una lavadora nunca se ha usado
es nueva para estrenar
además de daños civiles la tormentas
también azotaron los campos de cultivos
para exportaciones
es un cultivo de kiwi y como se mojó por
la inundación ya no se puede exportar
por lo que tendremos que despojarlo si
el cultivo sobrevive no lo sabemos en
este momento pero tiene 300 milímetros
de limo y el kiwi posiblemente morirá
como resultado de eso
las autoridades continúan actualizando
la cifra de fallecidos y hay temor por
aquellos sitios que permanecen
incomunicados
hemos publicado información sobre todas
las muertes de las que tenemos
conocimiento hasta ahora no tenemos
ningún otro cuerpo que esté con nosotros
A pesar de los rumores de que esto
abundó en la comunidad Durante los
últimos días y continuaremos con nuestra
investigación forense proceso que es
bastante estricto en la identificación
de cuerpos a medida que los obtenemos
actualmente hay casi 5.000 personas que
la policía no ha podido localizar y
alrededor de 62.000 hogares sin
electricidad mientras el gobierno
continúa sus esfuerzos por llevar
toneladas de comida y agua potable a las
comunidades afectadas